captain marvel will introduce carol
danvers to the marvel cinematic universe
on march 8th
early screenings have received fairly
positive responses and opening weekend
projections are anywhere from as low as
80 million dollars to the 150 to 180
million dollar range
and who are we kidding you know why
let's set all that other stuff aside
and just look at the character itself
and what captain marvel brings to the
mcu
marvel studios president kevin feige
confirmed to entertainment weekly that
captain marvel is the most
powerful hero the mcu has ever seen
considering the abilities we've seen
from some of the avengers already
that's saying quite a bit with cosmic
level powers including super strength
flight and the capacity to survive the
vacuum of space
captain marvel's skill set is closer to
that of dc
superman than anyone in the mcu
additionally captain marvel can absorb
any kind of energy
and release that energy as concentrated
blasts usually from her hands captain
marvel and avengers end game are the
final films of marvel's phase 3
an era that will have spanned 10 films
since 2016.
spider-man far from home will officially
kick off phase 4
and a new direction for marvel studios
marvel is known for unveiling their
release plans well in advance
but with phase 4 they've been slow to
confirm production of upcoming films
one reason for that may be the events of
these two movies and their world shaking
consequences for the mcu
how does the world's most profitable
film franchise get bigger
speaking at an event for ant-man and the
wasp kevin feige clued us in on the
direction the mcu's phase 4 will be
taking
he said i love cosmic stories and that's
why we didn't wait very long to get that
i'd say
thor was the beginning of that tesseract
and cap as well
i love it because i love space stuff and
i love the kind of stories you can tell
sounds like captain marvel will likely
be the beginning of a major narrative
shift to the universal and the infinite
in marvel comics the eternals are an
extraordinarily powerful
near immortal race of cosmic beings who
have existed for millions of years
thanos is an eternal with marvel's phase
four potentially shifting to a future in
the outer reaches of space
beginning in earnest with captain marvel
it's quite possible
audiences will get some eternals in this
movie marvel studios has already
confirmed that an eternals movie is in
the works for phase four
created by comic book legend jack kirby
the eternals and their enemies the
deviants
are two ancient alien races genetically
engineered by beings known as the
celestials
in the mcu kurt russell's ego the living
planet of guardians of the galaxy vol 2
was a celestial
we are forever
doesn't eternity get boring not if you
have a purpose peter
eternals have special powers well beyond
those of mortal men
it's implied that the eternals with
names closely resembling mythological
gods
were the true inspiration for those
myths in ancient times
if the mind of your inner nerd isn't
completely blown by just how cosmic the
mcu is about to get
starting with captain marvel then you
have a celestial level tolerance for
awesomeness
at san diego comic con in 2017 die hard
marvel fans were treated to some sweet
fan service
when marvel announced that captain
marvel would be the first mcu appearance
of the scrolls
the skrulls are a race of shape-shifting
aliens that have been around in the
comics since the early days
the ante was upped even more with the
news that the film would include a
narrative thread of the cree scroll war
a bitter intergalactic feud between the
two races first
introduced to comics in 1971 the cree
scroll conflict promises to be an
important aspect of world building for
the ever-expanding marvel cinematic
universe
speaking to entertainment weekly and a
new featurette co-director anna bowden
said
carol danvers knows the scrolls have
infiltrated earth and it kind of creates
this sense of paranoia
the scrolls are after something and part
of the mystery of the movie is carol
trying to figure out what they're after
and getting it before they do in the end
game trailer we see tony stark trapped
in a spacecraft that's out of fuel and
low on oxygen
theories abound about who will be the
one to save stark one theory that has
gained steam is the idea of
captain marvel coming to iron man's
rescue some look to the post-credits
scene in infinity war in which nick fury
pages carol danvers just before getting
dusted
as evidence of the possibility of a
captain marvel iron man team up on deck
for end game
one intriguing fan theory has outlined
an interesting role nick fury could play
in captain marvel
an astute redditor made waves by
predicting that 90s nick fury will be
shown or made aware of the future
and be persuaded to arrange the events
that we've witnessed on screen so far
in other words everything that has
happened in the mcu had to happen just
the way it did for the good guys to have
any chance at ultimately defeating
thanos with that kind of foresight fury
never needed both eyes after all
you want to stay ahead of me mr
secretary
you need to keep both eyes open the
supreme
intelligence is a little-known but
classic cosmic entity created by stan
lee and jack kirby
the character first appeared in a 1967
issue of fantastic four
this artificial intelligence was created
by the cree to help create a cosmic cube
as their enemies the scrolls had done
in the mcu the cosmic cube is also known
as the tesseract
more more recently the space stone on
thanos's infinity gauntlet
after much speculation annette benning
recently revealed her role in captain
marvel to be none other than the supreme
intelligence
who promises to be unlike any other
character we've met in the marvel
cinematic universe so far
during an interview on the late show
with stephen colbert benning described
her character as a god-like entity the
artificial intelligence
which consists of the greatest
intellects of the cree people
for the last million years speaking to
the hollywood reporter marvel studios
president kevin feige discussed the
prominent role female characters are
going to play in phase 4 and beyond
discussing the notion of making more
movies with female leads feige said
we feel like it'll be the first of many
there were a lot of men in that initial
run of avengers
indeed the next female driven mcu
project is reportedly already in the
works
black widow starring scarlett johansson
is rumored to begin filming in 2019
the movie will reportedly be released in
late 2020 or
early 2021 with additional details
likely becoming available once phase 4
begins with spider-man far from home
captain marvel wants to tell an origin
story but in a completely different way
speaking to mashable producer jonathan
schwartz said
in many ways it's a classic marvel
origin story but told in reverse
structurally you meet her as an awesome
badass super powered space hero
and then learn who the human is behind
that aspect of herself
the story begins on the planet hala
where she's deeply involved in the cree
scroll war
battling on the side of the cree people
and in full control of her potent
superpowers
the audience is then taken back to carol
danvers's home planet of earth where the
origin story proper begins
once there carol discovers her past may
hold the key to her struggles in the
present
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you